[Música]
boa tarde
obrigado pelo convite por aqui está
ainda mais pra falar de um de um tema
que nos é às vezes tão estranho tão
distante como a ópera
quem é que já foi para a ópera no brasil
duas três pessoas ivone levanta a mão
quem canta ópera canta ópera a aparece
hoje fácil dizer que fazer um festival
de ópera ou montar uma ópera é algo a
que qualquer um pode fazer e que eu acho
que pode fazer desde que tenha vontade
mas ter o festival de ópera em do paraná
o maior festival o maior evento lírico
do país
foi um desafio para quem criou o
festival e equipe que estava conosco que
começa lá em 2012 2013
e quando é concretizado em 2015 com uma
equipe de três pessoas e termina a
última edição no ano passado tendo uma
equipe de produção de 614 pessoas
eu lhes digo qual a empresa hoje que tem
614 colaboradores num núcleo só de
produção então fazer um evento nenhuma
linguagem não muito a feita não muito
próxima da população em geral
ainda mais no brasil ainda mais no
brasil é nos parecia um desafio muito
senão um desafio quase impossível mas
desafio que usaria um certo trabalho
porém estávamos e estamos em curitiba e
pegamos uma linha de um amor muito
grande não só pela cidade mas também
pela língua que se falava o melhor que
se fala em curitiba
entretanto o brasil tem mais 100 línguas
que se fala só que a gente priorize
obviamente a língua portuguesa e melhor
forma de não somente buscar aqueles
antigos amantes da ópera la do passado
uma vez que há uma década não tinham mas
não tínhamos mais ópera no palco do
guairão
era talvez fazer um novo público um
público jovem com a língua que se pensa
nós pensamos em ninguém
portuguesa seria muito difícil cativar
um novo público com uma obra em alemão
embora eu goste muito com ópera italiano
embora nós gostamos muito e aqui temos
uma formação tecnológica baseada muito
fortemente na na cultura alemã na
cultura italiana também a mas as óperas
em língua portuguesa o que baseou uma
grande leva é de pesquisadores depois do
início do festival de ópera do paraná a
pesquisarem essas peças que foram feitas
nos séculos passados e até pouco tempo
atrás e que ficarão no esquecimento a
chiquinha gonzaga é um exemplo disso né
quem diria que a grande maioria trina
chiquinha gonzaga que anos antes
é do seu estrelado 25 anos antes ser
conhecida praticamente no mundo inteiro
escrever uma ópera em maxixe uma ópera
com ritmos brasileiros
o chamado tango brasileiro nada mais é
do que o chorinho chiquinha gonzaga
escreveu uma má escreveu quatro dezenas
de óperas baseadas em ritmos brasileiros
que estão todas ou a ser wahda sou
guardadas ou esquecidas ou muitas delas
perdidas
embora o brasil consuma pouco esses
produtos culturais e tenhamos uma forte
obviamente influência de consumir as
óperas estrangeiras porque é isso que
mais se produz se nós montássemos e
buscássemos restaurar e montar a ópera
ea música que tem o nosso sotaque não
esperemos que um estrangeiro há de fazer
se nós não valorizarmos o que é nosso
não esperemos que os outros farão por
nós ainda mais na língua portuguesa que
é uma língua que embora seja entre as
cinco mais faladas do mundo é aquela que
é falado - países do mundo logo é não há
uma procura um mercado fora dos países
lusófonos
comecemos então começamos então lá em
2012 com a primeira peça primeira ópera
infantil a primeira peça de teatro que
vir ópera infantil da história do brasil
escrito em português por um certo
emiliano perneta hoje o nome de rua
príncipe dos poetas do do paraná
musicada por benedito nicolau dos santos
outro nome que pouca gente conhece porém
suas citações musicológicas de sua
teoria é citada exaustivamente obras
alemãs em dissertações de mestrado e
teses de doutorado mundo afora
curitibano nasceu e morreu aqui nem
parece que não dizer dito mas fizeram
eles a primeira peça infantil da
história do brasil
a primeira opereta para crianças em
língua portuguesa a vovozinha foi feita
em 11 9 refeito em 17 e até nações e 12
não tinha ela sido remontada ao
remontarmos na capela santa maria
percebemos que crianças de 8 anos
começaram a gostar de ópera e que aquele
público que pensávamos nós mesmos
produtores que era aquele público
restrito àquele público muito mais
fechado um rali público mais velho que
ele público de origem européia
nós imaginamos que aquelas crianças do
subúrbio de curitiba que mal falavam
português estavam rindo e gostando de
uma ópera para crianças numa ópera
lírica mostra com lirismo a isto é uma
ópera rock com aquele tipo de obra mesmo
aquelas vozes aquela coisa do encanto
típico da ópera é entendam o que para
nós foi uma uma mudança de paradigma
muito grande e para isso que criamos
aquele primeiro evento festival de ópera
do paraná sendo que o brasil não tinha
uma tradição de ópera muito grande
fundamentalmente os festivais
os festivais que existiam do amazonas do
pará e agora começou esse ano ou o de
pernambuco começou agora terminou há
poucos dias que foi muito parecido com o
nosso inclusive é todos eles têm uma
característica apenas de mostrar óperas
porém não formar público não trazer um
novo porém testamos e isso obviamente em
curitiba e esse é o grande motivo eu
quero brincar com a minha fala do porquê
curitiba porque da inter herdada do
interesse é das coisas a serem feitas
sempre em curitiba
afinal a ópera é uma obra ópera
a própria palavra diz é uma obra e até
hoje é tida pelos alemães por exemplo
como a arte a linguagem artística
perfeita porque envolve o canto ela
envolve a própria literatura com os
libretos envolvem a as artes visuais com
figurinos e cenário envolve a própria
arte educacional envolve hoje o
audiovisual que é utilizado sobremaneira
na europa nas projeções mapeadas e já em
projeções 3d e já começamos a ver na
europa é projeções holográficas de obra
inclusive podemos colocar aqui é um
poucos poucos meses uma maria calas rede
vida num palco cantando a ida ou
cantando ela traviata ou seja a qualquer
outra obra que seja então ainda podemos
dizer que a ópera é a linguagem
artística que consegue congregar todas
as outras linguagens numa sua produção
por isso a obra maior é uma ópera ópera
é a coisa e que os produtores artísticos
sabe a coisa mais difícil de se fazer
não só pelo público da ópera que precisa
ser feito ou pelos próprios cantores que
são seres muito diferenciados e eu me
coloco nesse meio por isso posso dizê lo
mas também pela dificuldade de juntar
todas as linguagens de uma só uma
sozinhas num só caminho porém o teste
foi feito em curitiba que curitiba tem
um diferencial para isso não só pelo
público
mas por que curitiba é uma cidade que
pode ser tudo testado e o festival de
ópera foi um dos grandes exemplos disso
e agora eu quero diz mostrar porque o
uso de andrade que foi o junto como foi
marido pagou foi marido da adaptação do
amaral dizia que contestaram um dever da
inteligência que se não contestar mos
não somos inteligentes não é inteligente
é aquele que não problematiza aquilo que
está à sua volta ao problematiza armos
algo que tínhamos no caso montar um
grande evento de ópera sabendo que as
grandes produções que quando vem pra cá
são muito caras e os auditórios sempre
vazio sempre vazios
entendemos que tínhamos de contestar o
modelo que se tinha ou pelos que se
fazia de ópera até então curitiba e tem
algumas singularidades
que nenhuma outra cidade do brasil e
quiçá poucas outras cidades do mundo
ontem a nossa formação territorial por
exemplo nós estamos tão próximos do
litoral porém ao mesmo tempo
historicamente tão distantes do litoral
olhem o nosso linguajar leite quente
para o linguajar do caiçara do litoral e
minha mãe era para o guará
como o nosso próprio linguajar é
diferente nosso nossos traços de alê
tais o nosso português dá apenas do
litoral problema no planalto já muda
porque foi ficamos isolados muito tempo
durante o século 17 18 até metade do
século 19 a uma ata da câmara municipal
de curitiba por exemplo que nos diz que
os povos de coritiba isto é curitiba e
hoje região dos campos gerais não comiam
comida com sal por mais de duas do dois
séculos não havia sal em curitiba era um
artigo de luxo só havia um isolamento
territorial e que notou isso dentro da
nossa característica com o povo ea nossa
localização geográfica obviamente que
favorece as entradas e saídas de
bandeiras e aqui é um outro tema de que
o brasil hoje deve grande parte do seu
tamanho territorial que tem graças às
bandeiras que saíram dos câmpus de
curitiba não seria o mato grosso
amazônia hoje tão discutida no rio
grande do sul brasileiro se não fosse
pela revogação do tratado de tordesilhas
que passou pela fundação de curitiba mas
já é um outro tema a nossa formação é a
única onde nós temos o maior agrupamento
de diferenças é épicas do mundo no
espaço no menor espaço territorial
não existe outro lugar no mundo nem nos
estados unidos onde que temos em - isto
é nós temos um tamanho territorial por
exemplo curitiba e região metropolitana
tamanho do líbano é o tamanho do líbano
é grande mas também não é tão grande e
mesmo assim nós temos é não apenas
representantes de etnias mas temos o
estabelecimento dessas etnias aqui nós
não podemos dizer que é um senador de um
árabe porque eu sou filho de árabes mas
um anime grado nos anos 40 não é mais
pré não deixa de ser brasileiro
o que ele ainda é um árbitro é
estabeleceu se essa formação é pública
fundamentalmente por conta da presença
polonesa e nós vamos daqui a pouco
porque nos dá um tipo de povo
diferenciado a auto-sustentabilidade
auto subsistência é e elenca uma série
de coisas aqui que nos fazem entender o
porquê curitiba é tão tão sui generis a
a ponto de ser mais tarde laboratório é
quantos produtos foram inventados e
testados a partir de curitiba se hoje
usamos pasta dental o dentifrício é
porque ôôô o stélvio da farmácia augusto
stellfeld naquele imóvel que fica na
praça tiradentes testou pela primeira
vez no brasil vendem dentifrício em tuba
na pasta em tudo inveja em pó e para
incentivar a venda ele dava um balão de
gás hélio é o vínculo civil última
dessas nesse identifica os alemães
vindos aqui em curitiba que estava na
mão da de um representante da família e
deu certo aqui o brasil então a doutor
ao uso de aviões para fins militares do
mundo inteiro primeiro foi testado em
curitiba e na região nós matamos uns
catarinenses na no contestado a e os
aposentados para trazer a orelha deles
num saquinho de sal ano pescoço e
colocava na praça hoje praça carlos
gomes que eram uma propriedade da
família a hada taborda ribas a eta ea
população dava dinheiro pelos militares
trazer mais orelhas direitas cortadas
dos catarinenses o que é uma fase rosa
essa história mas foi usado para ver os
aviões vezes deu certo opa o mundo
inteiro o doutor as temporadas
companhias líricas que vinham o
continente americano passava
primeiramente por curitiba isso até os
anos 30 até fechar em um teatro guaíra
em 36 no antigo rumo do jogo da bola
hoje o doutor muricy e depois o
restabelecimento do guaíra as temporadas
líricas de companhias estrangeiras
passam sempre por curitiba e estava
certo em curitiba o mundo pôde assistir
chicabon quem toma esse sorvete como é
que foi lançado no brasil
quando aquele inglês gostou muito
vamos menina chamada chica
mulata uma sancas muito vistosa no morro
da mangueira no rio de janeiro e fez o
sorvete de leite maltado ele pensou será
que dará certo no brasil
os fez ele chover chicabon sobre o
bairro das mercês com o avião teco-teco
em 1942 para forçar os curitibanos a
tomar um sorvete no caso chicabon e caso
os curitibanos gostassem daria certo no
resto do mundo e assim o fim e assim o
fez e assim os curitibanos gostaram
depois veio um jornalista do jornal o
dia correndo atrás da do povo em uma
coisa sobre sorvetes após o show e
dinheiro né
caso o banco iria se instalar aqui na
época talvez é a distribuição filme que
até os anos 40 começava sempre por
curitiba antes do rio de janeiro que é a
nossa capital o centro cívico de
curitiba a inspirou o brasil está nos
livros antanas depoimentos é não só a do
costa mas também do neymar se basear no
projeto do abacaxi em fazer o nosso
centro cívico para planejar brasília
começou por curitiba experiência os
primeiros ônibus articulados e
biarticulados do mundo
o menu do macdonald's lembram peçam pelo
número 12 começa em curitiba
os curitibanos não tivessem feito assim
não teria passado mundo a utilizar e
podemos tantas e tantas diretas-já por
exemplo o lixo guimarães antes de tentar
fazer na praça da sé em são paulo veio
para campo largo com a ser mezzadri rose
branca fez o comício em campo deu certo
em campo largo passou para curitiba no
outro dia a boca maldita encheu-se e
dali foram para a praça da sé porque
curitiba via dado o tom que estava na
hora de mudar talvez um mole e podemos
prever quantas né é a quantas status e
quantas e quantas franquias começaram
foram testados em curitiba antes de
serem distribuídas no brasil e no cone
sul
logo fazer o festival de ópera numa
cultura que não é enraizada na ópera é
de um público que não é majoritariamente
dado à ópera começar por curitiba talvez
fosse um bom
há um bom incentivo certo e não consegui
provar isso até agora pra vocês é e
assim o fizemos porque nós pensamos
sempre que a educação é base de tudo eu
discordo porque a educação sem a cultura
é um instrumento que pode ser utilizado
ideologicamente pelo estado
a escola sem cultura é um instrumento
ideológico do estado haja vista que
aconteceu na alemanha nazista era um
povo culto a filarmônica de berlim a
melhor oferta do planeta ainda tocava
todos os dias do chão de fábrica
o mais reles trabalhador tinha acesso a
concertos diários na sua fábrica da
orquestra filarmônica de berlim porque
havia educação mas não havia cultura ea
cultura sem educação é um mero
despreendimento é uma mera distração o
que junta a cultura ea educação
obviamente somos nós aqueles que fazemos
à cultura educação porém aqui daí é eu
eu bebo ladha do pensamento francês no
marlon que ele fala cultura tudo aquilo
que nós lembramos depois de esquecer
tudo aquilo que nós aprendemos como se
tirássemos de nós tudo aquilo que nos
impuseram o que sobrasse dentro de nós é
o que realmente é a cultura e é o que é
a ópera muitas vezes e ópera não fosse
popular
a ópera não sobreviveria até hoje disse
putin e não escutasse o cântico dos o
dos dos pescadores de luca lá na na
itália ele não teria feito áreas que até
hoje nós escutamos em filmes
então para que a ópera fosse popular
ainda hoje nós tínhamos que trazer isso
que isso ficasse recorrente fosse uma
parte da nossa cultura que fosse algo
tivesse dentro da gente e é por isso que
nós conseguimos fazer com que a ópera
atrás do festival de ópera do paraná que
vocês vão ver daqui alguns poucos meses
dois meses os outdoors na rua de volta
neste 5º festival
ao ter a a magnificiência que teve
sobremaneira por tratarmos ópera em
língua portuguesa
eu espero ter falado tão rápido que você
não possa entender e nem ter deixado
abordar algo que vocês tenham
comprometido entendimento ainda consegui
ganhar oito segundos antes do fim
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]